did you notice none of jack-in-the-box's
burgers have vegetables yeah they do
none of them
like the double western whatever all of
them it's all Patty and cheese and
sauces all of them what about the jump
doesn't Jumbo Jack have tomato on it
yeah yeah tomato and lettuce yeah
[Music]
so
um how do we feel about this did you
guys notice that different restaurant
chains like fast food ones are starting
to include Boba on their menu yeah oh
I've been seeing that [__] even [__]
like Arby's or something I'm like are
these Boba I think so I didn't know that
but one of those weird ones like a
Sonics or no there's a Jack In The Box
now Arby's has dim sum though dim some
Arby's
so Yoshinoya has had Boba for a while
now what kind of is that's adjacent yeah
it's adjacent right yeah but nice but
like you said Jack in the Box is now
running boba in certain locations as a
tester
I personally don't give a [__]
because it tastes like [__] anyways
right like if you want good Boba you go
to a Boba place and I think to me it's
actually good because it expands the
market people get used to it and then
they'll start drinking it and then after
a while like one of their other friends
will like go try this one and they're
like what is this and then they start
going to Jumby but you don't go to Jack
In The Box to get real anything like
imagine going there for the tacos you're
like authentic tacos
they're tacos are really good though and
their egg rolls are really good but they
they're in their own category like
that's not a taco in any sense it's its
own category its own thing yeah whatever
the [__] it is it's good right but it's
not but their egg rolls are good oh they
got a lot of good [__] they're good they
do because we do that [__] too yeah
[__] go to [__] JJ's Cafe and
there's a [__] club sandwich in there
you're like so it's like you know I was
like it's like the same [__] but I got
peeking duck inside yeah we got [__]
random
quail eggs and we also got club
sandwiches I didn't think about that it
is it's a Reuben in there yeah that is a
good point though it is a gateway like
it's a Gateway drink to like get it if
you liked it and you probably would have
never went to a straight up boba shop
because you don't know if you like it
you get it as a side thing and Jack In
The Box and then that becomes your new
thing yeah I bet they're gonna do their
own little Flair to it you know do you
think it in any way like uh it puts out
certain shot like let's say there's a
shop right next to it that's like a
dependent place like like a Tapioca yeah
because it's going to be more expensive
than Jack-in-the-Box right yeah I think
that's more of an issue of like
Starbucks next to a mom and pop like
it's almost irrelevant of the culture
it's just like when a big conglomerate
comes in what happens to the Mom and
Pops is what I think right but they can
still compete no matter what but there's
no way that the people who were going to
That Boba Place are gonna be oh Jack in
the Box is cheaper though like some old
Asian ladies like oh I think I'm gonna
go to Jack In The Box
never gonna happen no it's not never
gonna because even when I go to Jack In
The Box I know my doctor prep is gonna
be watery anyways so I'm like the rest
of the drinks just are extra [__] yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I do if they can't
do Dr Pepper right what's over dude how
are they gonna do a milk tea with Boba
have you guys had the Yoshinoya bobas no
is it good it's actually really good
what about the ones at Panda Express
because Panda Express got this I didn't
try this no I didn't what yeah but
yoshinoy has matcha they got milk tea
and then they got like a different like
all these coffee places got matcha Now
isn't that crazy but did you did you go
there because you were like I'm gonna
get boba or was it like I went there to
get my freaking beef bowl exactly and
you're like oh I'm curious I did that
exact thing and I was surprised how good
it was yeah it was actually good oh yeah
I thought I mean it's good because I
thought it was gonna super suck I don't
know if that's like playing into the
taste bud bias you know wouldn't you go
there for lunch you gotta try it in
Japan though you guys know that you have
a Boba place right I'm a connoisseur
that's what makes our Boba so good
because we actually try and eat all
kinds of [__] that's true you guys no
sometimes like we're really bad at sales
I think I shot it out earlier but Ryan's
setting it up and we're just talking
about everything else anytime someone
goes this is the newest joint I always
try it out too because I just like Boba
like regardless yeah it's nice to
compare it and I would just drink it I
don't know but all this place kind of
sucks but this place is really good you
know it's like when we went to a boba
time like that place sucks ass we went
to Bow time between filming and I I got
the matcha thing I was drinking from him
and I was just like oh man you can't get
this anywhere
is hands down one of the worst because
their size isn't even right it's not
even the traditional size what's the
traditional size it's like they have
their own size Boba that's like three
quarters oh the balls it's like buying
pants and you only get capris every time
yeah
[Applause]
isn't everything non-dairy as well I
think so but I think they're trying to
grab up the mainstream to like it's like
a Gateway Boba for like yeah
um ultimately when you go all the way up
the chain is it Chinese owned Korean
owned if you go up the chain it's
Taiwanese that's like the painted me of
Bobo yeah well I mean I mean like boba
time boba time what do you mean oh like
the owners yeah yeah yeah it's about the
company yeah the company owner but what
time I thought you were talking about
the Boba hierarchy pyramid none of that
but just like who who who's getting the
money who's getting the last dollar when
you probably like Kroger or some [__]
yeah
because
I thought it was like a bunch of Chinese
and Koreans that owned it but I don't I
don't really know
yeah where it came from so you guys are
cool with this Jack-in-the-Box thing you
completely completely chill with it I
mean it caught me off guard when I first
saw it I was like what the [__] and then
it makes me feel weird like not in not
from a cultural perspective but just
like seeing if I want to see your
outrage like if McDonald's like serve
pizza randomly what the [__] like the
same feeling right just because like
like I like branding so when I look at
things I'm like oh that's a brand I
understand like and I can almost predict
what other things are gonna do so when I
do something that's not predictable it
catches me off but as a boba shop like
owner that doesn't is there like an
opinion that you're expected to have
I wish Bart was like I'm Taiwanese and
I'm tired of people hijacking my calls
yeah say that that would have been so
good try it try it on try it yeah try
that try that narrative I'm so mad yeah
what are you mad about dude they keep
stealing my culture yeah yeah yeah what
else say it bro dude Channel your next
shark comments come on get your internet
yeah I think you're offended all the
time you're offended stop profiting off
of my culture they're victimizing my 23
and me yeah they're monetizing off my
answers to my 23andMe but what about me
dude because I'm like dude Jack in the
Box that's [__] white culture now we
got these Asian [__] moving in that's
the
because I'm thinking about the menu too
and I'm like dude you guys are getting
rid of all kinds of cool little options
and you're replacing it with all this
Asian [__] they got egg rolls on there
now they sent chicken teriyaki balls
they do here here's some top comments
from neck sharks post about it and some
of them make pretty good sense one
person says honestly if it allows me to
drink Boba at 2AM I'm gold that's tight
that's a convenient thing yeah yeah
because boba places aren't usually open
outside probably you know one of my
favorite things I don't know if they
have it anymore at Jack In The Box is
chicken fajita pita
remember that one the chick were they
banging what is it good I never had it
Jack-in-the-Box was one of the first
experiences to find dining that I had as
a child yeah because like when you go to
most places it's hamburgers but then you
start to explore outside of hamburgers
and you're like ooh Mediterranean
chicken fajita pita right and you have
egg rolls Mexican food
you're tasting the Coconuts yeah tasting
the cot in it
because the tacos are even like like
real shells
deep fried tortilla shells it's not like
the fake ones that you get at like Taco
Bell Jack in the Box is Continental baby
it's very if you haven't had a
jack-in-the-box Taco then you haven't
had a taco that is that is completely
wet
so it's true
it's so wet you can almost kind of see
through the taco it's like wait this is
a hard shell how come it's like a sponge
how did it get so wet it's all the oil
probably it's delicious all the goodness
dude now I just want Jack and box
turtles with some curly fries some curly
fries around I love their hot sauce bro
I love I don't know why I love
um their Taco is this like Taco hot
sauce right yeah did you notice none of
jack-in-the-box's burgers have
vegetables yeah of course yeah they do
none of them
like the double western whatever all of
them it's all Patty and cheese and
sauces all of them what about the does a
Jumbo Jack have tomato on it yeah tomato
and lettuce yeah
dude what misinformation again on JK the
sourdough whatever patted milk whatever
that's zero veggies like the Sourdough
Jack I don't know that they don't have
it yeah I think they have one tomato
they have one tomato on the Sourdough
Jack are you sure yeah I'm pretty sure
yo that's a game changer though you
could put everything on sourdough bread
oh my God that is okay I agree yeah put
Boba on it I do love it
I do love how mainstream Boba is
becoming yeah because that was one of my
worries about like opening up in Waikiki
because it's hell expensive right and I
was like well there's a lot of Asian
clientele and then the cool thing is
like we're like the only boba shop on
the Block oh yeah really yeah so it's
okay now let me ask you this if if Jack
in the Box is moving into your area like
across the street from you I don't care
it's Jack-in-the-Box we're high-end baby
that's smart you know that's like a
Forever 21 came in I'm Louis Vuitton I'm
like I don't care let's say that someone
comes into your place and they go I want
to go somewhere else that has better
Boba what's the nearest place oh they
got a whop bro yeah and Americans don't
walk it's a while there used to be one
like a block away and they closed down
they couldn't survive because you guys
are rounding up all their business you
took out a mom and pop shop no they were
already dying oh yeah they're already on
their way out because of covid it's not
my fault it shut down before coping yeah
they're practically dead in the water
should have made better Boba well the
funny thing is so like it kind of blew
my mind a lot of people that wanted like
the real [__] like the milk tea with the
Boba yeah it was of the white variety oh
wow and all the Asian people were like
let me get like the fruit purees and
then the different they wanted different
things right yeah and then so like like
Aussies would come through and then you
know they're just like do you have like
the popping Pearl and I'm like no and he
goes oh you just have the regular Boba
and I'm like yeah and then they wanted
just Black Milk teas or like they're
like what yeah or like when they order
matcha they just want it like the
ceremonial no sugar like the way they do
it in Japan so I'm like man you guys are
very cultured Aussies like to suffer
dude where they live man and then when
the Asian kids come in they're like can
I get extra sugar with this and they
just make it all crazy is there
something that um somebody's requested
that you're like I'm not gonna make that
well you're not supposed to mix Dairy
with like citrusy stuff that much not
Citrus um like acid or yeah like like
what was it was it like pineapple I
should know this [__] but it [__] your
stomach up oh it does
oh you can't have juices and milk
together
yeah yeah it's like you can't I know
there's like orange creamsicles and
stuff like that that's fine right
but like when it's too acidic and then
you mix it it can it can mess up a lot
of people's stomachs you know what
messed up my stomach one time speaking
of Jack in the Box I always said I was
getting a milkshake like I don't know
[__] 20 years ago oh they're so good
on it and they're like do you want it
malted and I was like yeah it sounds
good I'll get a strawberry malted and
that was whack what does that mean when
they molt it it's like some kind of it's
like powder that you just put yeah it's
some kind of powder they put in there
and it like tasted weird as [__] people
like malted I think it's like an old
school milkshake I don't know what it
means but it's I don't know what it
means either and it like you threw up oh
yeah I couldn't I couldn't drink it I
threw it right up yeah it was awful
don't do that the worst of food the
better my body absorbs it it's weird I
could eat [__] junk like Taco Bell
everything [__]
milkshakes and [__] my body digested
really good and the minute I eat a salad
out of [__] diarrhea that happens to
me with like
with fine dining wow like when I go to a
really fancy restaurant yeah and
someone's like oh you must try this yeah
it might be really I can't take like
fine
it might be the butter butter I can't
hungry after
[__] off dude sitting here eating food
okay cool I have to go to Taco Bell
after this thanks a lot
[Music]
foreign